Elon is in a lot of trouble with Twitter  he had to borrow 13 billion dollars to  be able to buy Twitter which means he's  gonna have to pay around a billion  dollars every year in just interest on  that loan which is bad because Twitter  is a horrible business that barely makes  any money so Elon is under a lot of  pressure to turn the company around fast  luckily he's got a few ideas up his  sleeve like making verified Twitter  users pay 20 a month to stay verified or  maybe even bring him back Vine but the  easiest way for Elon to make more money  firing Twitter's useless employees if he  were to Fire 3 000 of Twitter's overpaid  workers he would already save half a  billion dollars every year so subscribe  to find out what Elon ends up doing